so right over here i've graphed the
function y is equal to f of x i've
graphed it over this interval looks like
it's between 0 and some
positive value and i want to think about
the maximum and minimum points on this
so we've already talked a little bit
about absolute maximum and absolute
minimum points on an interval and those
are pretty obvious we hit a
maximum point right over here right at
the beginning of our interval looks like
when x is equal to zero this is the
absolute maximum point for the interval
and the absolute minimum point for the
interval happens at the other end point
so if this is a
this is b the absolute minimum point is
f of b
f b and the absolute maximum point is f
of a and it looks like a is equal to 0.
but you're probably thinking hey
there are other
kind of interesting points right over
here this point right over here it isn't
the largest we're not taking on this
value right over here is definitely not
the largest value is definitely not the
largest value that the function takes on
in that interval but relative to the
other values around it it seems like a
little bit of a hill it's larger than
the other ones locally it looks like a
little bit of a maximum and so that's
why this value right over here would be
called this value right over here let's
call this let's say this right over here
c
this is c so this is f of c
we would call
f of c
is a relative
relative maximum value
relative
maximum
value
and we're saying relative because it's
obviously the function takes on other
values that are larger than it but for
the x values near c
f of c is larger than all of those
similarly i can never say that word
similarly
if this point right over here is d
f of d looks like a relative f of d is a
relative minimum point or relative
minimum value
f of d is a relative
minimum or a local minimum value once
again there's in the over the whole
interval there's definitely points that
are lower and we hit an absolute minimum
for the interval at x is equal to b
but this is a relative minimum or a
local minimum because it's lower than
the as if we look at the x values around
d the the function at those values is
higher than when we get 2d
so let's think about you know it's it's
fine for me to say well you're at a
relative maximum if you're at a larger
if you hit a larger value of your
function than any of the surrounding
values and you're at a minimum if you're
at a smaller value than any of the
surrounding areas
but how could we write that
mathematically
so here i'll just give you the
definition that really is just a more
formal way of saying what we just said
so we say
we say that f of c
f c is
a relative
relative max
relative
maximum value
if
f of c
is greater than or equal to f of x
for
all x
for all
x
that we could say we could just say kind
of in a casual way for all x near for
all x near c so we could write it like
that but that's not too rigorous because
what does it mean to be near c and so a
more rigorous way of saying it for all x
that's within an open interval that's
within an open interval of
c minus h to c
plus h where h is some value greater
than
where h is some value greater than zero
so does that make sense well let's look
at it so let's construct an open
interval so it looks like for all of the
x values in
and you just have to find one open
interval there might be many open
intervals where this is true but if we
construct an open interval that looks
something like that so this value right
over here is c plus h that value right
over here c minus h and you see that
over that interval over that interval
the function at c f of c is definitely
greater than or equal to the value of
the function over any other part of that
open interval and so you could imagine i
encourage you to pause the video and you
could write out what the what the more
formal definition of a relative minimum
point would be well we would just write
let's take d as our relative minimum we
can say that f of d
is a
relative
minimum
point
if
f of d
is less than or equal to f of x
for
all x in an interval in an open interval
between
d minus h and d plus h
for
h is greater than zero so you can find
an interval here so this let's say this
is d plus h this is d minus h the
function over that interval
f of d is always less than or equal to
any of the other values the f of all of
these other x's in that interval and
that's why we say that it's a relative
minimum point so in everyday language
relative max if you're larger than the
then the if if the function takes on a
larger value the val at c then for the x
values around c and your relative
minimum value if the val if the function
takes on a lower value at d then for the
x values near d